what is
your purpose
man i know that's a crazy question
and maybe we could even be more specific
like what's the bigger purpose that
you're creating content on youtube for
if you're a business owner what is the
purpose and the big vision
for which your company
exists
in this video i'm actually going to be
talking about
our purpose here at think media why we
exist and we're actually hiring and
we're looking for purpose-driven leaders
and content creators and if you want to
inquire about some of the open positions
as well as a paid internship that we're
doing you could go to work with think
dot com for all of the details but i've
never really gotten real and raw about
our purpose
and the urgency of the work we're doing
at think media and why we're even hiring
right now and seeking to expand our
company and
if you're new to our content and whether
you're watching this on a youtube
channel or on our audio podcast you know
our purpose statement or a mission
statement is we want to help 10 000
purpose-driven people
create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with online
video
sometimes we a lot of times leave this
last part off but we also want to help
people achieve that success without
losing their soul
because a lot of people in the
influencer in youtube entrepreneur space
sometimes achieve success
and popularity and fame
but because there's a lack of character
they end up
in a crash
um
sometimes your chemistry or rather
sometimes your charisma can take you
farther than your character uh can keep
you and
so it is our heart that sometimes the
skill sets needed there's a lot of
burnout amongst content creators a lot
of burnout amongst entrepreneurs a lot
of burnout inside of companies and so we
are trying to achieve big things
but also achieve that success without
losing
our soul but there goes a lot deeper
than that and actually
i really wanted to make this video and
just kind of share some thoughts with
you
and this audio um that i just wrote down
about like man what really are we
fighting for
here at think media and maybe if you're
curious about man where does sean stand
where's the team stand what's the point
of think media what's the vision they're
going after
this will maybe give you some handles on
on
the nuances of
our
mission and and really we exist to help
people
and right now people need more help than
ever before
you know there's some really
discouraging stats
but this is the truth of the world we're
living in especially as we are going
into 2022
a new study from lancet estimates that
depression rose by 53 million globally
as a consequence of the pandemic that's
28 above pre-pandemic levels in cases of
anxiety
are 76 million that's a 26
rise
people need help
that right now with what's happening in
the world
people need help and we believe that
youtube is one of the ways for us to
help people but also for the people
we're educating and inspiring they need
to get their message out to help more
people in the united states a phenomenon
dubbed as the great resignation seems to
be picking up speed a record 4.3 million
u.s workers quit their jobs in august
according to new data from the labor
department a figure that expands to 20
million if you measured back to april
job displacement people without jobs
people being pushed out of their jobs by
new policies
consumer prices rose
at the fastest pace in 30 years for
september according to the wall street
journal nearly two-thirds of americans
describe the economy as poor in a new
poll that comes amid high inflation and
supply chain turmoil
in fact inflation is growing faster than
wages
additionally additionally uh president
biden recently said that any country
that out-educates us will out-compete us
now you might be watching this from
anywhere in the world but i'm not just
viewing that from a
u.s only perspective i'm just feeling
that that any
business any
individual any competitor in your
line of work
that is out educating
that that is out learning you
they're also going to out-compete you
and i believe that
the education system here in america is
failing
and
those relying on the system
are discovering that the system is
failing
and it's going to get worse before it
gets better if you're listening to this
you might be like dear god but like
meanwhile creators
many who have found fame on youtube and
tig tic toc are struggling with mental
health issues
burnout has affected generations of
social media creators
people are leaving platforms they're
saying they feel depressed and
discouraged
creators have huge skill gaps in
leadership emotional intelligence money
management and character development
that is resulting in pressure that is
breaking their marriages shattering
their mental health and leaving them
stuck and sometimes worse off when than
when they started
friend people need help right now
like society needs help
and the system is failing them
and people are looking for answers and
they're looking for alternatives broken
systems and broken ideologies and and
and
flawed solutions are not solving these
problems
so why does think media exist why are we
on this mission this is why we're on
this mission because our cause is urgent
and here's six things of of what we're
hoping to accomplish at think media
number one we are calling people out of
complacency and into courage
right now with all of the negativity and
culture there's a temptation to hide to
go on defense and to be complacent and
we're saying no you gotta come out of
complacency and step out in courage
we're not saying it's going to be easy
reinventing yourself and learning a new
skill set is not going to be easy but
you can either get pulled down with the
tide of culture right now or you can
rise up in courage and as a team and as
a company and in our content and in our
videos and in our audio and in our
events we are calling people out of
complacency and into courage too we are
calling influencers to realize that
charisma and popularity
without character were eventually lead
to a crash
what's funny
is
there's a lot of
negative aspects of social media and
influencer culture but i'm not here
cursing the darkness i'm here trying to
light a match
i love youtube i love social media i
love the opportunity that affords us
but the social dilemma is that there's
also a lot of destruct destructive
attributes of social media that if you
don't master it it can master you and
not only that that many people i've
watched now being in this industry over
years vloggers come and vloggers go
because their marriages blew up because
it leaked because of of habits and
destructive things that happened and
this is not coming from a place of
judgment this is coming from a place
that i can relate to as i've had
struggles over the years because how the
heck do you deal with the pressures of
fame and the pressures of being in
public and the pressures of the negative
comments and the pressures of of haters
and the mental pressure of trying to
just keep it going and will this exist
tomorrow i'm saying if you don't have
the character
then if you are full-time on youtube or
if you are a part of a high-growth
company if that that charisma and
popularity and money without character
will eventually lead to a crash
and we feel it as part of our calling
and our mission to think media is to
help leaders and content creators and
and digital media specialists and people
that are customer service professionals
and all the different attributes of at
think that that character is our is our
one of our highest values maybe you
heard our episode where it's the first
sea out of our five seas
and that without it eventually we're
going to lead to a crash we've seen too
many
popular influencers we've seen too many
pastors and too many best-selling
authors blow up their marriages blow up
their churches blow it up blow up their
lives because their character broke
we want to experience success without
losing our soul
and so we feel that our cause is urgent
to think media three our education
system is broken and people don't know
where to find real guidance and build
real skills that matter in the new
economy this is why our company exists
we
there's two kinds of teachers out there
there's real ones and there's fake ones
fake teachers are people that teach a
framework they teach a system they
describe how to do something and they've
never done it themselves
real ones are people who can teach the
framework teach how to do it from their
own experience because they've done it
themselves think media culture is we are
obsessed with being player coaches
that means that we don't just teach the
thing we live the thing and we do the
thing there's too many professors and
there's too many teachers and respect to
the real ones that have done it respect
to the real ones but there's just too
many of the education system that are
teaching theories and hypothesis but
haven't been in the trenches or the last
time they were in the trenches was 20
years ago or 30 years ago not only that
there's there's so many just outdated
models in the education system meanwhile
there is a movement and a revolution
happening
through online education through youtube
through people being able because the
gatekeepers are gone and they no longer
have to be locked away
in a university hall but that we can
actually freely give
real guidance
that builds real skills that matters in
the new economy
with the amount of job loss and
displacement of jobs and and with people
needing to learn things that actually
work in methodologies for building
online income for building online
businesses for becoming
strong leaders for building packaging
their education into the online course
movement or the affiliate marketing
movement or youtube or the creator
economy which is exploding or influencer
and brand deals people need real
guidance and we are obsessed with being
player coaches with bringing the best of
the best on our platforms and to our
events we are an education company and
the information we have matters more
than ever before and we need and this is
why we're convicted that we need to get
it into as many people's hands as
possible
our mission is urgent
number four we are helping people find
purpose and peace
we're helping people reconnect with god
and discover that life is a miracle in
the midst of a culture that is telling
them mankind evolved from primordial
suit
now you didn't maybe you didn't know i
was about to take it there and say well
is this really how's think media doing
that but i just mean
our conviction at think media
is that we were created by god
for a purpose
on purpose
and that life is a miracle and there's a
whole narrative telling people that they
just evolved from primordial soup and
you know what's interesting is the
co-discoverer of dna francis clark
admitted
the origin of life and i quote from his
book
seems to almost be a miracle
so many are the condition conditions
which would have had to have been
satisfied
to get it going
he continues to postulate
that the development and survival of the
fittest
is entirely a consequence of chance
mutations
seems to me a hypothesis based on no
evidence and irreconcilable with the
facts
these classic evolutionary theories are
a gross oversimplification of an
immensely complex and intricate mass of
facts and it amazes me that they are
swallowed so uncritically and readily
and for such a long time by so many
scientists without a murmur of protests
there's a quote from his book
published by simon schuster
so here's my thing this is not a
religious or political debate it's just
the mission think media is on is we are
helping people find purpose and peace
and from our point of view we are saying
people were created by god for a purpose
we're not an overly religious company
and helping people find cameras and find
you know how to do youtube we're not
trying to over spiritualize practical
skill sets that people need to build but
that is where we're coming from and
there is a narrative that is against
that truth woven into scientific facts
and and this is why our emerge our
mission is urgent because we see others
that have just as much free speech as we
do
that have a different ideology that i
believe does not lead to health and
longevity over the long haul but is
actually destructive and so this is why
we show up to work at think media number
five our culture
is in a crisis of confusion
depression and overwhelm
and weak policies of weak institutional
leaders are actually contributing to the
disempowerment of people
and we refuse that narrative we exist to
empower people build leaders and to
educate and inspire we exist to wake
people up and show them that freedom is
waiting for them
what do i mean
it's true our culture is more confused
than ever before more depressed than
over before more overwhelmed than ever
before
and we are witnessing that institutional
leaders are actually contributing to the
disempowerment of people not the
empowerment of people
see institutional leaders who are fat
with greed
obsessed with self-preservation and
perpetuating a system of dependency on
themselves
is leading to people being disempowered
meanwhile
this is what we do at think we freely
give and serve people with real tool
tools real truth and real guidance that
leads to real freedom
now of course
well sean you have a book for sale you
have online courses we do
but do you know we post 10 free videos a
week we post all over
social media free game being published
on all kinds of platforms
and not only that
we our most expensive online course
is 150th or 100th
of of a university or college if you're
gonna be a doctor you probably should go
to college
but there's when you consider the amount
of education and step-by-step guidance
that we give people listen not to just
build our empire but to build and
empower them to be sent out
institutional leaders and countries and
many ideologies are actually
trying to make people dependent on
themselves we are trying to help people
understand that they are free to build
themselves to go build that's why so
many people we get so many testimonies
we get so many stories of people that
have been impacted by think media and
they're already going to do the work
they're going to be change agents and
change makers we do not want anyone to
be dependent on think media
we are not trying to gather all untel
think media think media is not the
center of the universe we see ourselves
as a part of the solution
and those obsessed with greed and
self-preservation that are perpetuating
a system of dependency upon themselves
they're part of the problem
we don't seek to control people we seek
to empower and release people
by the way that's also the culture of
our team
i hope that our culture is so healthy
and that people love working at think
media so much that they do want to stay
working for think media
but we want to build leaders period
because the world needs leaders
we want to build change agents and
freedom fighters period because the
world needs people fighting for freedom
and truth
and so we're not trying to control
anybody we just hope to add value serve
build people up and that if people come
from think media and use our platform as
a launching pad and use our culture as a
place of development so that they can be
released to be change agents and culture
we say
let's do it
see this isn't about think media it's
about a bigger movement of freedom
fighters who refuse to capitulate to a
broken system and broken ideologies
so friend this is why
we need to get the think media content
and information into as many hands as
possible
why am i saying all this because i'm i'm
speaking to you specifically if you want
to be a part of our team what's the
conviction what is our purpose if you
want to go to work with think.com if you
want to intern in our paid internship
this is the urgency of what we feel
convicted to do here at think media we
need to get our content and information
into the hands of many as many people as
possible so this is why we want to
master social media and get our podcast
into as many people's hands as possible
and hear me i'm not s speaking from a
self-righteous pedestal
sean you clearly also want to build your
brand to make sales of your books or
your products or you want to sell
tickets to your event yeah because i
believe in it with my whole heart i
believe in what we're teaching i believe
in the value that we give i believe in
the stories that we've received i
believe in the countless we are
in detail studying
the success of our students we don't
just throw out platitudes and just think
oh the impact no we have our our staff
is measuring in monday.com we've
we're adding up how many views we've
helped our students get we've we're
adding up how many people are earning
their first 100 online their first four
thousand dollars online their first ten
thousand dollars a month by the way
online and we're studying that data we
have countless pictures of people with
their silver play buttons we have
countless pictures of people and then
it's not only the people we're
impacting but the people they're
impacting
we just think we're one smart small pete
the
small piece of a much bigger movement of
people that want to see change and want
to see good and want to see this world
become a better place and and that want
to oppose evil forces in this world and
be freedom fighters for good
so you better believe we think our
content is important and you better
believe we want to build a team of
strong people who are excellent in what
they do because we want to master these
channels of communication to get our
content into the hands of as many people
as possible
this is why we don't fear being
misunderstood
if you made it this far in this video
and you're like man you know who does
this guy think he is i understand that
you misunderstood if this is the first
video you see be like what's this guy on
man what's this energy i get it i don't
i'm not afraid of being misunderstood
i'm not afraid of the haters i'm not
afraid of the fact that people are
judging by headlines every single day
if you watch any
five minutes of somebody or just one
podcast of somebody or just one moment
of somebody
anything could be taken out of context
but we're not afraid of being
misunderstood we're not going to let a
fear of being misunderstood or
misinterpreted stop us or silence our
voice we're gonna shout even louder
see this is why we don't fear opposition
this is why we don't fear
if you try to do anything
you're gonna face opposition we're not
afraid of that we understand it comes
with the territory the only people who
don't face opposition is the people who
don't do anything so we're not afraid of
it
this is why
we are going harder than ever before at
think media because we are seeing that
things are heating up in the world and
they're not cooling down and that more
than ever before people need this again
people need ways of making money people
need education on taxes people need
education on saving and being
responsible people need to overcome
their vices that are like overspending
or like spending unwisely or like
spending on dumb stuff and investing in
wisdom so that they can adapt and evolve
and develop the necessary skill sets to
survive and thrive in the new economy
with inflation rising and with job loss
and with careers being disrupted and
with people working from home and with
people moving and with all of the health
challenges and all of the and with
rising competition with rising
censorship and with rising whatever
things are heating up they're not
cooling down
so leaders we got to get equipped we got
to get skills we got to get a vision we
got to get disciplined we got to get
moving
this is why it's so urgent the work
we're doing at think media
this is why we are freely flooding the
internet with truth value joy strategy
love and wisdom because destiny demands
that we play our part and make our mark
on history
freely flooding the internet
a lot of people say sean your free
content is better than most people's
paid content
this is why we are obsessed with
that's not it's not easy
that doesn't come because we just sort
of wing it and throw out some content
this is why we are obsessed with going
to deep places of study
mastering our craft the japanese concept
of kaizen and continuous improvement
this is why we're obsessed with
excellence this is why because it's out
of service
because on top of that then we post
videos and thank god
that we can monetize
free content in a lot of different ways
think about the era we're in
that eve that millions of people watch
our free content
and we have youtube ads
and brands pay us so that we can make
free content of course on top of that
it gets even better and goes even deeper
with our paid content but we're serving
people at all kinds of different levels
but our conviction
to freely flood
social media platforms
youtube to put out free
value on the internet
that's true
that's truly valuable that's truly
strategic
to share our joy and strategy and to
share we hope it comes across
authentic love that we care about you
like legitimately if you never buy a
book or a course or click an affiliate
link and if you never join the team but
if all you do is just listen to this
content and it inspires you
or provokes you to action or causes you
to dream bigger or causes you to reject
apathy to step out of complacency and to
step into courage and you're listening
to this for free right now
then our job is done
and we just want to make that mark on
history we hope we can make that mark on
your life and by the way the reason
we're trying to build a profitable
company is because we need money for the
mission because this mission matters so
yes unashamedly we are trying to make
more money because guess what allows us
to hire more people because guess what
it allows us to expand more places
because guess what it allows us to
invest in commercial real estate or
office spaces or
places to work or multiple states
or a global movement we don't we're
asking ourselves i don't know how far
this thing will go but as leaders we are
saying how far can we go together
how big can we dream together on the
think media team
what will i'll tell you this i'm a small
town kid college dropout
ten years ago
i'm in marysville washington
living in a house
that
in the in the bubble burst we were dual
income
sonya's health my wife
is devastated medical bills are piling
up but we can't make our house payments
so the house eventually short sales this
is on after the the big short
my church just blew up i was on a church
staff making like no money anyways
and some senior leaders character issues
this is where this fire comes from
because i've got to witness enough
movements crumble and leaders crumble
because they didn't deal with insecurity
and they didn't deal with character
issues and they didn't get healthy
relationships around them and and they
they let ego and pride go to their head
and they let in an incredible thing they
let a thing that was like guaranteed to
never stop they i've watched movements
that like just a few moves ahead
there was nothing but blessing ahead
but but character caused a crash or a
lack of character caused a crash
so the church is breaking down and we're
in financial devastation
and my wife's health she almost died in
2009 and 2010 she's in recovery
we have no prospects of the future
but we're staying optimistic we're
posting i'm posting youtube videos
trying to figure it out i'm doing my
business clearvision media i'm waiting
tables at red robin
and you want to think that i would think
i'd be making this video right now
was this the mission at the time no this
was not the mission at the time the
mission at the time was survival like
the mission of the time was like i don't
know can is it possible to make money
online like
you know like sean where did this all
come from this has come because we are
continue to ask ourselves as we reach
new heights man how far can we go how
much difference can we make as we
continue to
have bigger breakthroughs we want to
continue to give back and expand and
reinvest in the business and reinvest in
mission reinvest in people that's why
we're hiring
but you can you imagine
sitting in my seat right now
as i record this video podcast
and just
i don't even know it's crazy i it's like
i don't even know what i'm doing like
what the heck man you know what i mean
it's 2021 we're going into 2022
and 11 years later i'm like think media
is 18 people what the heck
i look at i look at our our team i look
at the stories that are getting
submitted every day we have team
meetings and we talk about the success
students we talk about the dms we're
getting we talk about the change lives
we talk about the people being inspired
all i'm trying to say
is how far can we go
and this is why we i'm asking how do we
scale it more how do we flood the
internet with more truth more value more
joy more strategy how do we do more
and not how do we do more and burn out
how do we share the load by building a
community and gathering a community of
leaders that can do more because i
believe and feel called that destiny
demands that we play our part and make
our mark on history
we don't think we're
bigger fish than we are we think we're
actually really
just a small group of people who love
people who love life who love god
and want to use our gifts and talents to
live up to our god-given potential to
serve others
to educate to share the knowledge we've
gained the wisdom we've gained to pass
it along that others could go further
faster
and we do that on like 10 different
levels free youtube video podcast
want to get a book we've got new books
coming out want to come to an event we
do free events we do free meetups we do
paid events want to get a course we've
got courses at different price points
want to come to a mastermind we're
helping business leaders at higher
levels
that are trying to figure out how to go
from
six figures to multiple six figures more
money for the mission we're trying to
figure out people trying to break the
seven figure lit at every level it's
just customer journey that's the same
journey we've been on ourselves and
we're just asking ourselves how can we
do more and make
our mark on history this is why we do
what we do are you getting value out of
this is this too heavy i mean
this is this is our purpose i hope this
is inspiring you to think about your
purpose
and and this is why we're looking for
purpose-driven leaders and content
creators as i land the plane
number six this isn't about think media
or i don't know what number i'm on th
this this is why we are
being more focused and strategic and
disciplined than ever before
because we do work that matters
and so i know this is crazy but but uh
we're looking for purpose-driven leaders
and content creators this is why we're
going through another round of hiring
work with think.com but this is also why
we're doing something we've never done
before and we're doing a paid internship
and i don't know
um where you are in life you might
already be established in your career
you might be in a situation where you
know a minimum wage internship is is not
quite you know
meet your needs right now but wherever
you are in the journey if you'd say man
i resonate with this what is what is the
point of it all we have a couple full
full-time positions but the point of the
internship
is there's about a 30-day trial if you
qualify if there's a vibe there and we
start
we can synergize
up to six months
and then at six months either you've
learned a lot and you've helped us and
you've grown and you've been a part of
what we're doing or you'll get hired on
the team
so it's an internship with the
possibility of joining think media
full-time
and and so
you could see details at work with
think.com but if your heart's burning to
say like man i just resonate with i've
maybe always wanted to be a part of
thinker and i would love to to
you know be a content creator or think
personality or i'd love to um you know
bring my sales skills or my customer
relation skills or my event uh
management or i'd love to i just want to
lead i'm just passionate i'm hungry i'm
willing to learn
um and it's open to
living in vegas is great we're really
looking for interns that live in vegas
we're looking for interns that want to
move to vegas
or that want to work remote and there's
certainly the opportunity to do digital
marketing and social or video editing
and things like that and you don't have
to necessarily live here local but our
vision man is is we really do feel like
we're purpose driven
um this is the purpose
the world
is in a lot of crisis
but we're not cursed in the darkness
we're trying to light a match
the world has a lot of challenges right
now we're not trying to overly complain
about the problems we're just trying to
bring solutions and we believe
that the pursuit of wisdom and that
growing as leaders
and that
developing character and developing
relevant skill sets
will be a part of the solution to the
world's problems
that there needs to be more good online
and there needs to be more leaders in
culture there needs to be more leaders
in their nonprofits and churches and
businesses and independent content
creators and we need more people
that are fighting for freedom and
fighting for good in this world i think
media is just trying to do our part
so if you want to uh check out details
go to workwiththink.com if you're
watching this some place where you can
leave a comment i'm curious did you get
anything out of this drop a comment and
did this resonate with you that did this
inspire you and i also hope to put some
handles on this question for you what's
your purpose
what is the bigger purpose you're
fighting for
what is what is it you hope to build
with your business
with your youtube channel with your
content with your personal brand
as a speaker as an author as a real
estate agent like whatever you're doing
this is the real reason why i think
media exists and this is our vision as
it continues to unfold and the purpose
for which we fight and friends i think
it's urgent
and the work we do is needed
our current team is on a mission
together and i it could be that you are
needed as well and i mean we definitely
need people we need leaders resonates
with you go to work with think.com and
apply did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle get over 1
900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
[Music]
you